what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and what better way to end 2022 and
start off 2023 then by talking about the
best moments from Marvel Studios in
2022. now there have been mixed feelings
about phase four as a whole however
despite your feelings whatever you think
you can't deny that there's been some
amazing moments from phase four in 2022
and these moments are actually coming
from you all the fans I asked you all on
Twitter and Instagram which moments were
your favorite from 2022 you answered and
I've gathered the most popular responses
and put them in this video also if
you're not following us on Instagram and
Twitter please do so so I just want to
start this off by saying that a lot of
people mentioned Spider-Man no way home
which technically came out in 2021
however it was still in theaters in 2022
so of course we shall count it
I mean it's really hard not to count all
three Spider-Man being on screen
together it was just amazing plus not to
mention we had things happen like
Spider-Man fighting the Green Goblin and
Happy's apartment building and Andrew
Garfield's Spider-Man saved MJ he got
his Redemption So Beautiful Moments from
that movie that kind of did start off
2022 for us however the first actual
movie of 2022 was Multiverse of Madness
doctor strange 2. and this movie oof it
had some really really cool moments it
does have mixed reviews as well but it
did have some truly amazing moments it
was cool to see the MCU get a little bit
darker than normal and it was absolutely
awesome to see the Scarlet Witch being a
villain and to see her absolutely wreck
a bunch of people in a bunch of
different scenes this was one of the
best parts of phase four a big scene
that everybody talked about was Wanda
telling doctor strange that she was
being reasonable this is me being
reasonable
this gave a lot of people chills and
then of course the Illuminati definitely
makes it to the top moments of 2022.
seeing John Krasinski as Mr Fantastic
was breathtaking when he came on the
screen and we saw him for the very first
time everybody screamed then of course
seeing Patrick Stewart returned was also
amazing we also got Black Bolt and
Captain Carter in live action then we
saw them get absolutely destroyed which
was sad but still pretty dang Epic
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
walking it was really really cool to see
the Scarlet Witch do this however it was
really really cool to see doctor strange
go into the dead Strange's body and I
didn't hear about this scene but
personally for me I think we got one of
the best Marvel quotes of all time from
this film where Doctor Strange tells
Christine Palmer I love you in every
Universe there were a lot of Great
Moments so let us know what your
favorite moment was from Multiverse
Madness in the comments down below NOW
Thor love and thunder wow another movie
that has very mixed reviews I thought it
was pretty epic though and let's talk
about what fans enjoyed about it I heard
a lot about Christian Bale and he was
pretty dang good as a villain he was a
little weird but the character was
supposed to be that way and Christian
Bale played it pretty perfectly now
people talked a lot about the opening
scene specifically where Thor did the
splits to stop two of those vehicles
from hitting him and of course it's just
truly awesome to see Thor War fighting
with the Guardians of the Galaxy
alongside of them so pretty much the
whole opening scene with Thor in the
Guardians of the Galaxy before they part
ways was pretty dang epic then we got
Jane as the Mighty Thor this really was
cool to see I love Natalie Portman but I
really love the way that she used
mjolnir the broken mjolnir how it would
shatter into pieces those pieces would
hit people and then come back together
that was awesome that also leads us to
the scene as why she could wield mjolnir
Thor making mjolnir promise to always
protect her that was a pretty cool way
of Jane Foster being worthy enough to
lift up mjolnir and speaking of mjolnir
it was really cool to see the love
triangle between mjolnir Stormbreaker
and Thor I personally love that comedy
and it's good to hear that a lot of
people loved it as well
what you up to bro
[Music]
I was just calling you now perhaps one
of the coolest things that we got from
phase four was
eternity showing up in Thor love and
thunder this to me was actually one of
the coolest scenes in the entirety of
the MCU to see a cosmic entity and I
personally love the way that they showed
him and I'm really looking forward to
seeing more Cosmic entities in the MCU
and then we move on to Black Panther
wakanda forever this one was very heavy
it may not have been a perfect movie
however there were some very
hard-hitting scenes very impactful
scenes starting of course with
t'challa's funeral simply watching
Everybody mourn him and I mean everybody
not just the characters but the actors
who were playing the characters as well
and the people who were watching as well
who love t'challa and Chadwick it was
pretty emotional and it was very heavy
however at the same time it was truly
great to see t'challa and Chadwick of
course honored and of course we have to
talk about shuri becoming the Black
Panther her entrance was pretty dang
cool the first time she suited up as the
Black Panther and it was a really big
moment of the MCU now Namor or no more
as they say in the movie and telecon
were just fantastic simply amazing Tena
guerta was perfect as Namor an excellent
performance by him and I think what I
saw the most for a great scene in 2022
was Neymar attacking wakanda and killing
Queen raimonda
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
come on
[Music]
showing how ruthless he was and showing
no mercy he set out to make a point and
he did so by killing the queen of
wakanda it was super intense and it was
really awesome now also the ending of
the movie the post-credits scene where
we found out that t'challa and Nakia had
a kid this was very impactful as well
but most importantly this kind of tells
us that Marvel is essentially recasting
t'challa we found out that his son's
name is indeed t'challa as well so
whatever stories they need moving
forward that have to do with t'challa
from the Marvel Comics they can still do
with his son but simply act like he's
the same version so whether that's
t'challa get in with storm and marrying
her that is still possible so this was a
very big scene and now we move on to the
Disney Plus shows and the Disney plus
specials starting with Moon Knight and
out of all of the Disney Plus shows that
we got this year this one was definitely
my favorite Oscar Isaac Stephen Mark
Jake they were all great to me and
seeing Oscar Isaac suit up as Moon
Knight for the very first time was truly
epic I saw that one talked about a lot
online and then where Stephen tried to
fight on his own for the first time and
he gave us that classic my name is
Steven with a v-line
[Music]
what
what
I did it you got planted then we had
actual Gods fighting each other that was
pretty insane to see in a very different
side of the MCU very different gods we
had Egyptian gods here and the whole
entire Vibe of sort of the ancient Egypt
Indiana Jones and the mummy type of fear
was really really cool as well the suit
itself was pretty fantastic and I really
loved the whole psychological Thriller
aspect that the show had to it it was
also really cool seeing Moon Knight and
the Scarlet Scarab fighting together but
I think the scene that was talked about
most online was when Steven and Mark see
the hippo the goddess towerette
foreign
[Applause]
and that was probably the best scene of
Moon Knight now werewolf By Night the
Disney plus special this was
unexpectedly awesome I don't typically
like things in this genre but this was
really good and the whole thing was
insanely good just the entire thing from
man thing melting heads and crushing
people to Jack Russell actually turning
into werewolf by night and Elsa being
absolutely terrified in the cell then
from there the violence was actually
really awesome werewolf By Night killing
everybody and then the ending of Jack
and man thing simply sitting there
together having a meal I definitely
think this was one of the best things to
come from 2022. along with the Guardians
holiday special this was just wholesome
and was really funny and it had a lot of
great scenes from us finding out that
the Guardians bought nowhere from The
Collector then mantis and Drax going to
Earth the two of them getting Drunk
Together the two of them kidnapping
Kevin Bacon Drax getting his little
Christmas guy these were all very
wholesome and funny scenes also nebula
got Bucky's arm for rocket it rocket
finally got Bucky's arm and then of
course to top it all off Star-Lord has
found out that mantis is his sister
which was awesome now moving on to Miss
Marvel didn't get a ton about Miss
Marvel actually not a lot in the
comments of my post however the scenes
that were talked about were all pretty
much the same a lot of people had said
that one of the best parts was in the
very final episode when Miss Marvel said
and begin and we pretty much saw the
true powers of Miss Marvel in that scene
but of course from Miss Marvel we did
get one of the biggest moments in MCU
history the name drop of mutants and
while that was dropped we heard the
X-Men 97 Theme played in the background
as well this was truly an historical
moment for the MCU and then the scene
that was second most mentioned was Miss
Marvel and Captain Marvel switching
places at the end and we're about to
find out what's going on there this year
in the Marvels and to top it all off we
end with She-Hulk now most of what we
got for She-Hulk was about Daredevil of
course simply Daredevil just appearing
and She-Hulk was amazing Charlie Cox
back as Daredevil simply fantastic I
think the scene that most people talked
about however was Daredevil's walk of
shame
and that is truly a great scene then the
scene where he has to explain to
She-Hulk who he is where he says I'm
Daredevil
soup like the gold devil
I'm Daredevil
and of course everybody was talking
about the ending whether you liked it or
hated it everybody was talking about it
She-Hulk breaks out of her show into the
real world breaking the fourth wall goes
into Marvel Studios and talks to Kevin
where she then proceeds to change the
entire ending of her show whether you
like that or not it was something to
behold and that would end our Disney
Plus shows for 2022. what was your
favorite moment from 2022 be sure to let
us know what was your favorite project
and what was your favorite moment and by
the way those can be two completely
different things you could love one
project but your favorite moment could
come from a different one so let us know
down below and don't forget to follow us
on Instagram and Twitter please don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
to the channel so you don't miss out on
any of the videos coming in 2023 thank
you all for a very awesome year and we
look forward to another great one next
year and as always thank you all so much
for watching woof woof